THEORY AND NATURAL ORIGIN
THEORY CALLING ATTACKS HIMSELF
HIM BASELESS.
>> THAT ISSUE WITH MASKS IS
PEOPLE WANT TO FIRE ME OR PUT
ME IN JAIL FOR WHAT I’VE DONE,
NAMELY FOLLOW THE SCIENCE.
I COULD GO THE NEXT HALF HOUR
GOING THROUGH EACH AND EVERY
POINT THAT THEY MAKE.
>> I KNOW.
>> IT’S PREPOSTEROUS.
>> CAN YOU IMAGINE ANY
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE PRESIDENT
BIDEN WOULD EVER FIRE DR. FAUCI?
>> NO.
>> MANY REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS
ARE EAGER TO HAVE DR. FAUCI
RETURN TO CAPITOL HILL AND
TESTIFY.
>> Harris: LUCAS, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
CRITICS ARE HITTING BACK AT DR.
FAUCI’S REMARKS.
ONE TWEETED ONLY A SOCIOPATH
NARCISSIST SPEAKS OF THEMSELVES
IN THE THIRD PERSON.
ANOTHER WRITES FAUCI COMES OFF
LIKE AN ANGRY TYRANT.
SENATOR MARSHA BLACKBURN IS
WITH ME NOW, REPUBLICAN FROM
TENNESSEE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
FIRST OF ALL, HOW SERIOUS AND
WHAT LEVEL OF EFFECTIVENESS IS
THIS DISCUSSION ON CAPITOL HILL
AMONG SENATORS ABOUT FAUCI
LEAVING?
>> IT IS A VERY EFFECTIVE
DISCUSSION.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN SO HEAVILY
IMPACTED BY THIS VIRUS ARE
WANTING SOME ANSWERS.
WHEN YOU LOOK THROUGH THIS
CORRESPONDENCE AND THESE EMAILS
FROM DR. FAUCI TO HIS STAFF,
HIS CONCERNS OVER GAIN OF
FUNCTION RESEARCH, HIS TENDENCY
TO WORK WITH MARK ZUCKERBERG TO
CREATE A P.R. CAMPAIGN WHERE HE
WOULD CHERRY PICK FACTS AND
DETAILS, THE WAY HE HAS BEEN
FOR THINGS AND AGAINST THINGS.
THE WAY FACEBOOK WORKED TO
SILENCE ANY POST THAT HAD TO DO
WITH A LAB LEAK THEORY, THEN
YOU PUT THAT, HARRIS, WITH WHAT
WE ALREADY KNOW.
WE KNOW THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY LOCKED DOWN THE PROVINCE.
IF YOU WERE FROM WUHAN YOU
COULD NOT GO SOMEWHERE ELSE IN
CHINA.
BUT YOU COULD GO TO THE WUHAN
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT AND FLY
TO THE U.S. OR THE E.U.
WE KNOW THAT THE W.H.O. AND OUR
DIPLOMATIC SCIENTISTS WERE
BLOCKED FROM GOING INTO THAT
LAB.
WE KNOW THAT DR. FAUCI HAD
CONCERNS ABOUT THE MONEY THAT
HIS AGENCY SENT TO THAT LAB FOR
CORONAVIRUS RESEARCH.
WE KNOW THE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH.
THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT ARE
KNOWN.
AND THEN YOU LOOK AT HIS
ACTIONS.
HE IS DOING WITH BIG MEDIA AND
CHUCK TODD EXACTLY WHAT HE DID
WITH BIG TECH AND MARK
ZUCKERBERG IN TRYING TO BUILD
OUT A P.R. CAMPAIGN, CLAIM THAT
IF YOU SAY ANYTHING ABOUT HIM
YOU ARE ATTACKING SCIENCE.
AND IT IS SO INTERESTING
BECAUSE I’M ONE OF THOSE.
I STAND WITH SCIENCE AND
GETTING TO THE BOTTOM OF WHAT
SCIENCE WOULD TELL US ABOUT
THIS.
THE TYPE RESEARCH THEY WERE
DOING, WHY WERE THEY TRYING TO
COVER IT UP?
THESE ARE ANSWERS THAT WE HAVE
3 1/2 MILLION PEOPLE ON THE
FACE OF THE EARTH THAT LOST
THEIR LIVES.
WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF FAMILIES THAT WERE AFFECTED
BY DEATH, BY ILLNESS, BY LOSS
OF LIVELIHOOD.
WE HAVE PRECIOUS CHILDREN THAT
LOST A YEAR OF SCHOOL AND
SOCIALIZATION AND NOW HAVE
EMOTIONAL PROBLEMS.
HARRIS, THE PEOPLE HAVE SEEN
THEIR TAX DOLLARS USED AND NOW
THEY HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
IT WAS USED, WHO BENEFITED FROM
THIS, AND WHY IS DR. FAUCI
PROTECTING THE WUHAN LAB AND
THE CCP?
>> Harris: YOU ARE GOING BACK
AND SHOWING US THE FACTS THAT
WERE COMING IN DURING WHAT YOU
MIGHT CALL THE WORST PART OF
THE PANDEMIC AND MAYBE THEY
WENT BY THE WAYSIDE BECAUSE
PEOPLE COULDN’T CONCENTRATE ON
THEM.
WHEN YOU TALK SPECIFICALLY AS
YOU DID WITH THE FACTS ABOUT
THAT LAB, WHERE DOES THAT PUT
DR. FAUCI?
JUST QUICKLY WE’LL MOVE ON BUT
I AM JUST CURIOUS.
WHERE DOES THAT PUT HIM AND
WHERE DOES THAT PUT PRESIDENT
BIDEN?
>> DR. FAUCI SHOULD SAY I’M
GOING TO STEP AWAY WHILE THIS
IS INVESTIGATED.
THAT WOULD BE THE RIGHT THING
TO DO.
HE IS A BUREAUCRAT WHO HAS BEEN
CAUGHT.
HE HAS DUG A HOLE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SHOULD SAY
WE’RE GOING TO HOLD THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY, THE WUHAN
INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY AND DR.
FAUCI RESPONSIBLE WHILE WE
FIGURE OUT WHAT HAPPENED
BECAUSE WE DO NOT EVER, EVER
WANT TO GO BACK THROUGH THIS
AGAIN.
>> Harris: ALL RIGHT.
WE’LL MOVE TO THIS.
IOWA IS JOINING SEVERAL OTHER
STATES IN BANNING TEACHING THE
CONTROVERSIAL FAR-LEFT CRITICAL
RACE THEORY THAT ASSERTS THAT
AMERICA IS INHERENTLY RACIST AS
A COUNTRY.
FLORIDA’S EDUCATION BOARD COULD
PASS A SIMILAR BAN TODAY.
THIS IS HAPPENING VERY QUICKLY.
A VIRGINIA MOM WHO SURVIVED
CHINA BEFORE COMING TO AMERICA
IS COMPARING RACE THEORY TO THE
REVOLUTION SHE ESCAPED.
HERE IS SOME OF HER POWERFUL
SPEECH AT THE LOUDON COUNTY
SCHOOL BOARD.
>> I’VE BEEN VERY ALARMED WHAT
IS GOING ON IN OUR SCHOOL.
ARE YOU NOW TEACHING AND
TRAINING OUR CHILDREN TO THE
SOCIAL JUSTICE WARRIORS AND
LOATH OUR COUNTRY AND HISTORY.
THIS IS INDEED AMERICAN VERSION
OF THE CHINESE CULTURAL
REVOLUTION.
CRITICAL RACE THEORY HAS ITS
ROOTS IN MARXISM AND SHOULD
HAVE NO PLACE IN OUR SCHOOLS.
>> Harris: WHERE IS ALL OF THIS
CRT COMING FROM WHEN YOU HEAR
IT COMPARED TO THAT, WOULDN’T
EVERYBODY WANT TO AT LEAST
QUESTION IF NOT PUSH AGAINST IT?
>> I HEAR FROM MOMS EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
AND I HEAR FROM FRIENDS WHO ARE
NATURALIZED CITIZENS.
THEY ARE INCREDIBLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS.
THEY DO NOT WANT OUR CHILDREN
TO BE TAUGHT TO JUDGE PEOPLE BY
THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN.
THEY WANT OUR CHILDREN TO LOVE
THIS COUNTRY.
THEY WANT OUR CHILDREN TO KNOW
THAT WE ARE A LAND OF FREEDOM.
WE ARE A LAND OF OPPORTUNITY.
THAT EVERYONE HAS EQUAL ACCESS
TO OPPORTUNITY, TO MAKE THEIR
DREAMS COME TRUE.
AND AS THEY ARE LOOKING AT WHAT
THEIR CHILDREN ARE BEING
TAUGHT, THEY ARE HORRIFIED WITH
THIS.
AND THEY WANT OUR CHILDREN TO
KNOW HISTORY, TO KNOW CIVICS,
TO APPRECIATE THE FREEDOMS THAT
THEY HAVE.
I THINK THIS IS WHY SO MANY
SCHOOL BOARDS AND SO MANY
STATES LIKE TENNESSEE HAVE
BANNED THE TEACHING OF CRT IN
THEIR CLASSROOMS.
>> Harris: SENATOR REAL QUICKLY
IOWA DEMOCRATS ACCUSED
REPUBLICANS GOING AGAINST THEIR
OWN PUSH FOR FREE SPEECH BY
VOTING TO BAN CRITICAL RACE
THEORY.
HERE IS WHAT THEY WRITE.
WE CAN’T SAY ON ONE HAND WE
WANT FREEDOM OF SPEECH AND ON
THE OTHER HAND SAY WE WANT TO
HEAR BOTH SIDES, THEN STIFLE
THOSE SIDES.
A QUICK RESPONSE FROM YOU.
>> WHEN YOU ARE STANDING ON
PRINCIPLE AND TEACHING OUR
NATION’S HISTORY AND YOU WANT
TO HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW
OUR NATION HAS GROWN, THAT IS
ONE THING.
BUT TO SAY OUR NATION, HERE IS
THE 1619 PROJECT, THIS IS THE
TRUTH, THIS IS THE ONLY THING
YOU ARE GOING TO HEAR, THAT IS
NOT RIGHT.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT OUR
STATES ARE PUTTING A STOP TO
THIS RIGHT NOW.
>> Harris: SENATOR MARSHA
BLACKBURN, REALLY, REALLY GOOD
TO HAVE YOU ON THE PROGRAM AS
YOU TALK TO US ABOUT THE PUSH
AGAINST DR. FAUCI ON THE HILL
AND CRITICAL RACE THEORY AS
IT’S COMING INTO VIEW WITH MORE